>>Girl: What does it mean to
make the world a better place?
>>Lindsey: Nice! So those are those
big questions we're focusing on.
>>Lindsey: For me, being Trauma-Informed
has so much to do with mindset.
Accepting that different people
come into a school setting
with incredibly varied life experiences.
Some of those life experiences may
be traumatic and the way in which
that plays out in my particular
classroom could look a number of ways
and by me having that
lens, it makes it less
about are they doing the right
thing or the wrong thing,
and more about where is
that behavior coming from?
Why is that happening?
>>Dr Cantor: Adverse childhood
experiences like poverty, neglect,
exposure to violence can bring
about overwhelming stress,
which can cause negative effects on
the learning brain and on behavior.
If children have the
experience of adversity.
They will have uneven development
of these foundational skills,
like self-regulation, and executive
function, or relationship skills.
These are the children who are at risk
to fall further and further behind.
But the good news is that there
is a powerful antidote to stress
and that is the effect of the human
relationship and the presence of trust.
Schools are an ideal place to produce
many different kinds of relationships
that are capable of buffering stress.
Schools, themselves,
can be healing places.
>>Dr Darling-Hammond: If you're fearful,
if you're anxious, if you're distracted
about something that's happened
to you, you literally can't learn.
Your brain shuts down.
So it's essential to give kids social
and emotional tools that allow students
to recover from the challenges
that they have experienced.
Take actual classroom time to
work on the building blocks of how
to perceive your emotions, how to
talk about them, how to get along
with other people, how to take a moment
and become calm when you need to.
How to express your needs so
that others can meet them.
>>Dr Cantor: When we start to understand
what it takes to be responsive
to the effects of trauma, we need
to think about the environment,
about individual services, and we need
to think about the skills and mindsets
of kids that won't develop as they
should when they're impacted by trauma.
>>Lindsey: I do a lot of work
around self-awareness and being able
to name emotions and then
make a choice around those.
>>Boy: When I get mad, I take deep
breaths and that helps me get more calm.
>>Lindsey: Hm.
>>Dr Darling-Hammond: Many of the
things we think about doing for who kids
who may have experienced
trauma are good for everybody.
And everyone will encounter some
kind of adverse circumstance
at some point in their life.
And for some children,
we're helping them deal
with what's already happened
in their lives.
For others, we're preparing them to deal
with the challenges later
in their lives.
>>Lindsey: If you can hear my
voice, say, "We are awesome!"
>>Class: [clapping] We are awesome!